then all stars we if we send each other
home right rupaul doesn't get to make
any decisions RuPaul just sits back and
just just watches I feel like we have to
choose who gets to go home yet they
remember like oh no be strategic that
kind of stuff
it's a fun game to play it's a really
fun game to play okay I think that
sometimes people forget it is like it's
a game it's a game that you have to play
while also being entertaining I know I
can outperform these [ __ ] who've been
at it for like before I was born
it's so nuts to be here on the Thames
using with you you are a legend thank
you that's so cool I mean I remember
when I first met Lady Bunny
when I'm first moved to New York City
you're my lady bunny oh my gosh Lady
Bunny is old as the dinosaur okay I
thank you I guess then you have Queens
like Naomi smalls being like I grew up
watching you yeah that like freaks me
out you know because I I've just I've
always known a RuPaul I don't even know
like how old Leia's white how old I was
when I when I first like knew of her or
heard of her so to like be on the flip
side of like the oh there's like these
up-and-coming drag queens who I consider
legendary drag queens because I watched
them on RuPaul's Drag Race right
respective seasons and so I just I just
see them as my drag race sister I just
don't realize that yeah they were in
high school watching me yeah it makes me
feel old but hey I mean it sure beats
the alternative hey you're still out
there still working yep
I'm still working still uh still high
kicking and jump splittin but you're
glad you did it I am so happy to have
been able to do it it was a lot of fun
yeah I mean it's like I get to be a drag
queen I get to like come up with like a
whole bunch of cute costumes and show it
off to the world and you know make make
Michelle visage gag a little bit and
just you know get to it you don't get to
show off it's really it's really fun
there are worse ways to spend your life
oh yeah for sure for sure
yeah I mean no complaints here
[Music]